tous les cils
souci de soucis
souci de suta silence
oubliez qui s'élance
dis moi seul à quoi tu penses
dans le huit
dc ou
tu te jje en instance
tuer la juge valable il est la victime
sans défense
le manque de courage des filles mais tu
l'appelles manque de chance
l'avant je mens ouais city
on le passera sous silence
pour des croyances futile
glisser dessous des silences
certitude qui s'élance
dis moi seul à quoi tu penses
tuer la juge maladie
elle dans son âme et conscience
en laisse ou son site ici
au hasard de telle méfiance tu es celui
qui vacille sous le poids de sa violence
on les a vu ses profits
mais de tout est silence
pour tes secrets immobile
celi dessous des silences
oubliée et qui s'élance
dis moi seul après tu penses
smoothie de soude ici
souci de soute et silence
oubliée et qui s'élance
dis moi seul à toi tu penses